hi everyone my name is Richard I'm a
third-year PhD student at UC Berkeley in
the rice lab and the primary focus of
research right now is high parameter
tuning so I'm gonna be talking really
quickly today about high-power tuning
for specifically deep learning workloads
and to motivate kind of the the whole
premise of this talk if you stepped
outside of your door anytime to secure
you know that everyone and their dog is
excited about deep learning and the
reason why this is can be attributed to
the recent successes in fields such as
thing which processing robotics and
computer vision and as a programmer this
is great because a hoss has also driven
the development of nice easy fun to use
frameworks so so let's first take a look
at a function we have here this is a
typical program structure for a computer
vision task and so if you look very
clearly here is within three lines of
code you can construct a model or this
is high-level but you construct a model
you create your optimizer and you
iterate over your data set using the
optimizer to update your model so this
is pretty simple but really there's a
dirty secret here which is that or
there's a couple of dirty secrets first
of all the training process is gonna
take a lot of time so so that's gonna be
bad and then you're also using it likely
using a GP or multiple GPUs because
otherwise it's infeasible to do and this
is gonna cost you a lot of money and the
final biggest dirty secret here is that
that every abstraction here actually has
plenty of configuration knobs which
we're gonna call hyper parameters and
you're gonna want to change maybe the
the architecture of your model or just
learning rate and momentum or even
change the way pre-processed data now
the fact of the matter is that if you
for a lot of these problems if you have
to optimize you you'll have to optimize
your hybrid parameters and this can
seriously affect your performance often
in unintuitive ways so here on the
screen for example there's a common deep
reinforcement learning task for control
that's plotted with different hyper
parameters and unexpectedly the smallest
model
works the best so this is weird and this
is bad because what this means is that
there's three goals and they're all kind
of like in tension with each other
you want to maximize performance you
want to minimize the time spent and you
want to save money so this kind of sets
up the premise of today's talk we're
going to be talking to be over viewing a
couple techniques that people have come
up with to deal with these issues so
there's gonna be five main techniques
that we're going to be covering today so
obviously we're gonna talk really
quickly about the the basic grid search
and random searching and Bayesian
optimization might also be a staple for
this crowd but we're also gonna be
talking about bandits specifically hyper
ban and OSHA which were which are a kind
of like modern techniques for hypercam
tuning developed at UC Berkeley and then
population-based training which is a
sort of a deep learning specific
technique for high premiere optimization
to help that google deepmind so again
some of these techniques are kind of
applicable to the standard machine
learning regime but some of these
techniques such as hyperventilation
based training have much more
significance in the deep learning regime
so real quickly I'm going to be using
this maybe like this term trial and
that's gonna be sort of specifying like
one configuration evaluation just in
case people don't get lost so let's
start with grid search this is a very
simple and standard technique for
evaluating multiple high parameter
values and even though this may seem
naive there's a couple benefits so again
the TLDR of this is that you take a
cross product of all possible
configurations and you have a list of
values across different dimensions so
the the benefit of this is that it's
very easily parallelizable and also it
provides a lot of insight about how your
hybrid parameters affect each other and
this is very important in cases such as
research now the problem is that if
you're simply trying to optimize your
model accuracy this technique is
actually very very inefficient so so
here's here's some intuition why so
let's take a look at this graph right
here there's a very standard graphical
tician of white grid search can be can
fail to be a good tuning method so on
the left-hand side here we have a grid
search that fully misses the optimum
point of them or even close to the
optimum point of this what we call this
important parameter which is shown on
the x-axis and random search which I'm
gonna talk about next is able to provide
much better coverage across the
different hyper parameters in exchange
for this sort of like structural
analysis that you get and
interpretability that you get from grid
search so let's quickly talk about
random search next at a high level so
you basically just sample configurations
or over a set set distribution over and
over again and users are it's up to the
user to specify the distribution there's
a couple benefits for doing random
search so as mentioned previously and
provides better coverage than grid
search and also it is easily
parallelizable
so each since each of these evaluations
is an independent sample now it turns
out in high dimensions it's actually
very very hard to be random search now
now the problem with random search is
that we're so there's still quite a few
things that we can do better here and
after all you're trying things at random
so one obviously obvious thing that you
can do here is that maybe maybe just
maybe you can use the prior information
from the evaluated training runs from
previous runs to guide our tuning
process well so turns out this is what
Bayesian optimization does and and a
high general rate Jenna in general this
is what model-based optimization
processes do so so this is a very
high-level overview of Bayesian
optimization so without diving into too
many details so like here's here's a
very rough abstraction for what you
would typically use for a Bayesian
optimization algorithm or library so
what what you do is you make construct
an optimizer that is aware of the search
space so here we have these balance of
the low value and the high value for
both learning rate and the layers
now what we will do is over the course
of some number of samples we will sample
from the optimizer to get a a
configuration and the configuration is
going to have some value for the
learning rate and the layers and we're
going to then train a model using this
configuration to get a final scores such
as a validation or loss so then we pass
this information back to the optimizer
and then we resample from the we tell
the optimizer to provide another sample
configuration so so the optimizer will
then use the information from prior
results to generate a new next point to
sample within the space and ultimately
this will this aims to optimize a given
score or accuracy or value and so so
this is a very high-level abstraction
I'm not gonna dive into the mathematical
details and and but there's a lot of
open-source libraries that provide
exactly this abstraction and most
famously you might have heard of
something like hyper opt but as you can
see there's a couple benefits to this
but one thing to note is that Bayesian
optimization is an inherently sequential
process which means that the benefit of
this like using prior information is
dependent on these prior trials so so
what this means is that if you want to
paralyze this which you actually can
give in recent research you can sample
multiple points at once but the benefit
of this parallelization actually
decreases significantly as you add more
workers so so so this is nice we can we
can parallelize Bayesian optimization
now and we can also use utilize this
prior information now there's still some
some room for improvement
so-so so by taking a look let's take a
look really quickly at what typical
training curve looks like so we have
this graph of training run inaccuracies
and there's law of models in this graph
that are simply bad performers
and these might just be simple simply
different hyper cameras that you're
trying over the course of your training
run so and this is gonna be the case for
all of the prior methods including a
grid search random search and Bayesian
optimization so keep in mind that
Bayesian optimization even though it
ends up finding a better solution using
prior information it still needs to
explore the search space so you're going
to end up with a lot of these like bad
bad training runs so naturally you might
ask well why bother wasting resources
aren't trials that simply are not going
to be good and turns out there's a hyper
parameter technique for you so this is
Cod so this technique is called hyper
band which is an early stopping
algorithm that aims to allocate
resources through better performing
trials and let's quickly walk through
some pseudocode about how this works the
high-level intuition is that you compare
relative performance for all these
training runs you terminate the ones
that are bad performing and you continue
the better ones for a longer period of
time and you do this in an iterative
fashion so that so eventually you have
better childs that that that are bad
compared to its relative other
performers and you were gonna kill the
mayor and continue them for even longer
period of time so let's take a look at
the pseudocode so we're getting our
first sample from the hyper parameter
space this right now for the purpose of
actually the original paper just assumes
you do random search and so so when the
as we're gonna run the trial or we're
gonna run this training run with this
hyper parameter configuration so we're
gonna keep running until we hit this
slight pre-designated cutoff so this pre
designated cutoff isn't actually when we
stop a child but is rather when we
evaluate the relative performance so if
the trial and the performance is and the
top fraction which is user specified but
usually one third of the trials at this
training iteration or epoch then if
since we are wrong the best we're going
to keep running it now if you are not in
one of the best we're just going to
pause you and we're going
to that another child start now what's
nice about this is that again this is an
adaptive method so if you have a
training run that that may be you know
very very like inefficient and very so
very bad in the very beginning then then
we will we will be able to terminate it
really quickly so one thing to know here
is that there's actually even recent
advances that have made hyper band
capable of being combined with Bayesian
optimization and since hyper band is
very easily parallelizable this can
increase its efficiency even more so so
now now given all this I can use an
early stopping method within bayesian
optimization method so this gets you
very very far already now now what's
next what's next in the deep learning
world well turns out in deep learning hi
programmers schedules matter a lot so
what this means is that we may change
the value of the hyper parameter such as
learning rate and momentum during the
course of training and this is actually
required in the law of computer vision
tasks and even natural language
processing tasks yes they are results so
so so what what what can we do to
address this well there's a technique
from Google that that actually is able
to explore these dynamic high parameters
schedules so this technique is called
population based training or otherwise
known as PBT it's a technique from
google deepmind that addresses this
issue and the main idea is that you
evaluate a population of high parameters
in parallel you terminate the lowest
performers and you copy weights from the
best performance and and you mutate
these best performers a little bit in
replacement of these lowest performers
so so let's take a look at this quick
walkthrough so i'm gonna start off with
say four different hyper-paranoid values
so i have four members in my population
i'm going to then actually just run it
until for a some set number of it
and then I'm going to evaluate the the
relative performance of each but let's
say the 0.4 value is the worst so so
what I'm gonna do next is I'm going to
take the best performer which I
arbitrary designated as 0.1 and I'm
going to perturb the value a little bit
to 0.15 but I'm going to copy the
weights the neural network weights to
that new perform to that new trial which
has that mutated hyper parameters so
note that this is effectively like
searching over a hyper parameter
schedule so I'm going to keep running
this and say say I I I find out that the
0.2 value is the worse after a set
number of epochs and then also 0.3 it's
actually performing very very well so
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to kill the 0.2 value population member
and then I'm going to take the 0.3 I'm
not going to perturb it and so on and so
forth so again the main benefits of this
is that people pop nation based training
this is easily parallelizable enables
you to search over schedules and is
efficient in that it early terminates
bad performers now you might be
wondering okay well this seems kind of
hand wavy does it really work so turns
out deepmind ran this technique over
multiple published algorithms and
including tasks in NLP gans and deep
reinforcement learning techniques so so
they found that across the board Peabody
was able to provide non-trivial
performance benefits over the state of
our published results for these these
papers that they had published earlier
in previous years so so that's that's I
think that that's something that you
have to have in your toolbox if you're
doing some deep learning hypercam
realization so now you might be thinking
okay well there's no way I'm going to
actually implement all these algorithms
so so I I'm here then to talk about tune
which is a distributed hi programming
search library from the rice lab that
that provides an easy-to-use interface
for all of these algorithms I
listed before and then I'm gonna walk
into a demo that that kind of shows you
how to take use of these these these
algorithms using tuned so tuna is the
joint work of many faculty members
graduate students and undergraduates at
UC Berkeley and tune is specifically a
library that handles the execution of
hyper image search so it provides hooks
to plug in to different high parameter
search algorithms while automatically
handling the parallelism for you so this
means that again you don't need so you
don't need to change your code if you're
running on your laptop or on a big
multi-gpu machine or across a cluster
and then we'll talk a little bit more
about this later and show you a demo so
why is tun special tune is built with
deep learning as a priority so this
means that tune is built so that you can
effectively utilize a spreader training
across GPUs or multiple GPUs per trial
tune also allows users to tune their
model with any machine learning
framework and again tune is able to
allow you to run hyper in tuning at any
scale so that means from running one
single process to running across
multiple GPUs to running across multiple
nodes all without changing your code
tune offers many algorithms for
optimizing your high program research
including all the algorithms mentioned
today tune also integrates with many
open source hyper and search libraries
such as hyper robbed and accent acts
from Facebook which means that you can
transparently scale these search
libraries across multiple GPUs and
multiple nodes Jun is also integrated in
too many open popular open source
projects such as Allen tune which is
open source tuning solution for NLP from
the Allen Institute in Seattle and soft
learning which is a popular we are a
library from UC Berkeley tune is also
used in various organizations for tuning
deep learning and deep reinforcement
learning models so tune also outputs
tensor boards automatically so that you
can take care of you don't need to take
care of like instrumenting your code so
that you can visualize things and allows
you to analyze your exists
trials to determine correlations and
performance across different trials and
parameters so so with this I'm gonna
then go into a demo this real quick so
I'm gonna demonstrate how you can
utilize some of these hyper parameter
search libraries using tune and I'm
gonna show that it's it's very easy to
do specifically I'll be going over
setting up a standard grid search and
I'm going to be trying out a a scaled
out run with hyper opt and then and then
another what run using hyper band so so
I have all these imports here and and
I'm going to first just run this and and
then I have this training run in in PI
torch now what you see here is that this
is we're going to be using a cluster of
sixteen GPUs across two nodes and so I
want to be using this cuda device thing
which which allows me to put my model
onto the GPU and and so what you can do
here in order to use tune with this
training run which looks very standard
is simply to add this like this track
log thing from tune which calls into
tune to that it to to inform you about
the the current training accuracy and so
tuna was gonna use this information to
determine relative performance and then
terminate the existing training run if
it's a bad performing trial so so so
that's that's just call this method and
what I'm going to do is I'm also going
to connect to the Rae cluster which is
kind of like what allows us to paralyze
tune across multiple nodes so tune is
backed by Ray which is a distributed
execution engine in PI
and rate allows you to transparently
parallelized functions and classes
across nodes and you can find out more
online but at a high level this is what
its gonna take to to connect to the raid
cluster and then I'm gonna check my
cluster if my cluster is up and I think
it is so yeah so I have oh I guess I
only have one oh I have a cheap used by
half two nodes so so what that means is
that each node has four GPUs all right
so so I'm gonna start with grits with
actually a random search so so what I
have here is like a hyper paranoid
configuration and there's gonna be a
uniform search over this this lower
bound in the upper bound and a log
uniform search over this lower bound and
upper bound and this is gonna be like a
base-10 log form log uniform sampling so
to actually just use tune here i can
just run with this command so chin dot
run i'm gonna pass in this this this
function i'm gonna specify that i'm
gonna want to use a GPU so trial one so
so note that you can specify all sorts
of different resources including memory
and ntp use and so on and so forth and
i'm gonna pass in this configuration
right here which is kinda specify my
hyper parameters search space and i'm
gonna set this verbosity so that I don't
have an explosion of things so this
should be it and we can try this for a
run oh so
so right now this is using one training
run now note that we have a cheapy use
on in our entire cluster so we can
naturally paralyze this so what I'm
gonna do then is I'm just going to
increase the number of samples after
this training run finishes so let's say
something like 20 so this is this is
done and we got an actor see a 0.65 now
if we want to do a random search with 10
and 20 different trials we can just
specify this and this is due but you can
see here we we've sampled all the
configurations first and we have eight
trials that are running in parallel and
each of them is progressing at different
rates but you can see that some of them
have better performances than the other
and so so after this finishes then we
can move on to hyper opt but actually I
might just move on to that first because
it's gonna take a while but anyways so
so for Hyper opt which is a again like a
a model based optimization method which
utilize prior trials four four four four
four like better search in in in trials
that that it determines to try next it's
gonna require some some some
specification here in tune so where it
has its own way of specifying trials or
i specifying a search space and i've
already written this year in advance but
what we can do here is we can say we can
use the same to not run configuration
from here and instead of passing in this
configuration here I can specify a
search algorithm and here instead of
this I'm going to give this training run
a name
which might be something like I brought
this will help me differentiate their
trials later on or differentiate the the
plots later on and the information
that's logged later on so in order to to
utilize the search algorithm well I do
is I just specify this hyperope search
constructor which is provided with tune
I'm going to pass in the space which is
the high parameter search space which is
a native hyperope construct then I'm
also going to specify the maximum number
of a train of concurrent trials I'm
going to run note that again that's best
as as I mentioned before the more
concurrency you add to the training run
the the worse it's going to do for this
sort of model based optimization method
so I'm gonna just specify something like
like for and then for a high prop to
kind of know which which accuracy to
optimize on I'm going to just tell it to
optimize on on the mean accuracy which
was specified which was passed in in the
in the in the method for train then this
into the track dot log and then I'm
going to pass I'm going to tell it to
optimize this by maximizing so so just
with this simple just like one extra
configuration right here we're able to
scale out hyper opt across two notes for
with a cheapy use with a GPUs and you
you basically don't need to handle any
of the distribution yourself and so
what's nice about this is that again as
promised we have only for concurrent
trials running out once and and ideally
after some time we'll see that that's
that more more the trials are going to
get better and better
so so the final thing that we want to
take a look at is Asha which is also
known as asynchronous hyper band so I'm
gonna start typing this out as as the
previous hyperope training run is
running and then at the end I can do a
quick visualization over these training
runs so I'm gonna take again this this
this training and I'm gonna try actually
just merging using both asynchronous
hyper band and hyper opt at the same
time so this again allows me to be
resources efficient and and optimize
over a search space using prior
information so the way I would do this
is just specifying this configuration or
specifying a scheduler and we call it
the scheduler because it manages
resources but but maybe you better like
machine learning charm is like algorithm
and the only thing I need to do here is
just pass in modem metric the metric and
the mode so so there's four left that's
running and you can see that well it's
kind of hard to see but it should get
better and better
yeah but these are the last four that's
running and then we can maybe increase
the concurrency for this because I don't
want wait too long but ideally we can
also use the async in cyber band
scheduler to further optimize our
training and yeah but while we're
waiting for this I can take some
questions I guess I was curious about
first of all will you have this code
available sure okay cool
and then second of all how easy is it to
like not only tune model parameters but
like data pre-processing parameters and
stuff with tune yeah so actually that's
we actually wrote a paper on that and we
were using tune and I can send I can
like post the repository with with the
slides and this is like a published work
at ICML last year okay yeah thank you
[Music]
yes so just to quickly overview this
this hyper hyper hyper op plus hyper
band you see that there's a lot of
trials that it's running for just a
short period of time and it's able to
determine a really really efficiently
because it finds out that there's a lot
of trials that that just don't don't
work very well meanwhile it's able to
find really high performing trials very
quickly and so unfortunately I mixed up
these these names but maybe we can do
something like this
I'm run it again I can do some
visualization on tensor board any other
questions so in one of the previous
slides when when you explained how PBT
works
population-based think there was only
one wearable so but in reality there
will be a set of variables which are
performing good and which one how do you
know which one to mutate
right so so this is a limitation of the
algorithm and it's generally what they
do is they just they down scope the
scope the number of parameters that they
evaluate and since it's a Google paper
they also like run this at large scale
so so it tends to be that like that that
it works out for them but but right now
this is just ongoing research that's
like how we can do better for that all
right so I guess the last thing I want
to show is technically we can visualize
this on tensor board within the jupiter
notebook so we're not maybe this is just
a jupiter limitation let's see all right
well I guess there's there's nothing to
show here but like technically you
should be able to see like a
jupiter-like like an in-place plugin for
a tensor board within within like a trip
notebook maybe it doesn't work for
jupiter that so that's it
any other questions yeah presumably
there's like some PI data channel for
doing this is there
yeah presentation plus like the being to
the github I can post like the slides
with the presentation or i sorry the
link to like this repository there with
solutions right here on like a separate
slide in the presentation that i post
online if that's thanks for the talk it
seems like you know all of these methods
depend on the score being very smooth a
pretty smooth over the head parameter
space and you know because it's very
spiky it's low chance to any of these
methods would happen to land on a nice
scoring spike and so do you know like do
we or do we know in general if most deep
learning algorithms have a pretty smooth
scoring space and studies would be
relevant or I guess what's the general
research on that yeah so I mean I think
there's so speaking of like supervised
learning and and even like unsupervised
learning these those sort of like very
standard like models for training
attempt to have curves that you should
be able to smooth out so if you take
like a moving average there it tends to
work kind of well now where everything
goes to like goes goes down like the
black hole is like when you start
playing with like control out like so
like deep reinforcement learning things
so you'll see things that like go up and
down and and it's it's a huge mess so so
for those those things like so like what
Google does because I mean deep mind is
a reinforcement learning like factory
after all they just like throw like a
hundred machines plus like
population-based training to to push
their algorithms yeah
so after you've like found your best
model what is the way to then like
export the correct parameters yes so so
right now what I've done here is I have
this like save method that actually
saves it within the right path now now
let's see so so I have this like
analysis object and I can get like
analysis not yet like best or larger
yeah so this should work and so I have
this logged ER and and as as you saw it
upended the I have a path for the the
model that I've saved here but I can
also LS I think I'm not sure if I can
Louis wait so yeah so there's like
parameters here and then there's like a
model that's already saved and then
there's also like you know tensor tensor
flow
tensor board things that that are not
nice to me today but yeah in your
experience how does the tune pipeline
scale with the number of layers you have
in your model oh yeah so at some point
like if you're if you're adding like
many many there's in your model like it
like this is just a general general
notion of hyper parameter search and
it's gonna be hard for you to do
optimization like any smart intelligent
optimization there the reason why is
because like for these like these like
like optimization libraries like like
you like you can imagine like if I have
like three there's if I range from like
two to five there's or two to ten
there's and each there has like some
like I want to specify like the size of
each there like
you're not going to you're going to
explore like but the 10 like thus like
the size of the 10th they are very very
infrequently as compared to like the
second there and so like this is kind of
like this like really construed space
for like searching over things and and
for those cases like it tends to be that
like random search can like basically
beat a lot of these like model-based
algorithms yeah so I wasn't sure if I
saw this parameter in but how does this
work with like a validation set like a
test and validation set yes so that's up
to you that's sort of like up to you to
specify within this this training run so
right now what we do is like we we
ignore the training accuracy and we do
this test set which returns the sackers
like this accuracy value that we logged
and we used for our optimization does
that answer your question yeah so the
high-level idea here is that like we
just like provide like very limited like
abstractions for you to to do things and
rather like push it all to the user for
them to sort of set up their own
training runs and stuff like that
thank you Richard Lao for lateness
through a talk of - parameter tuning
algorithms
I was really cool you mean give us like
walk through example everyone please
give them a round of applause
[Applause]